so in the movie you know one thing that
stuck out is you know you get asked to
what your biggest fear
what would your biggest fear be in real
life God thank you sure in real life um
sharks are out there sharks very live
very the library it's kind of morbid
sharks and well I guess you know I
didn't want to get to know him and I'm
talking I didn't want to talk like you
know regret is being good to us back I
was just going to go simple yeah no one
wants to be eaten by a shark right
it's like fear McKenna you want to go
beneath a shark what's your biggest fear
McKenna your honor guys I don't like the
dark and I don't like closets those are
very stupid fears I'm sorry um jeez
is it because you think things are maybe
in the closet because they're all so
dark it's like a double it's like two
and one I don't like cause just I don't
my pants I don't know why but something
bout them freaks me out
what um um well that's all I can think
of okay dad that's why when I was your
age I felt the exact same way it's not
as more of a difference yeah yeah my
mind really Laurel graphics um it's
interesting because in this movie you
know obviously you're a math whiz and
you know parenting has kind of evolved
and change over the years where now and
also speaking to you as an actress
you're speaking of adults all day and is
there you know a lot of people say
should speak to kids like adults
is there topics for kids that should
still be off-limits
hmm I think it probably depends on the
kid I've certainly met some kids on the
topic fair enough
these are topics you wouldn't discuss
McKenna I don't know but there could be
something that children don't know like
me because I don't know I don't know
like there could be something that they
haven't been discussed with yet like
what if you were let like treating me
like I'm a grown-up and you said
something I didn't know
sure sure and then I had to like
then I was really confused like what are
you talking about you know mm-hmm
very true well says yeah sure the
chemistry in this movie is great
you and Jenny obviously have an amazing
chemistry was that something right away
or is that something that developed over
the course of the film
I mean honestly this is one of these
movies that to me it felt to me yeah it
kind of felt like right away first time
I'm in mark the first time I met Octavia
years ago no way
same with Jenny first time I met Jenny
it just instant when you're like out
this person is just going to be my
closest friend yeah
first time I met mechanic so you know
Paul McKenna she was there to audition
did still she just came in and just had
this light about her and soon as she
walked out the room you're like that's
the girl and and just she's so you know
you can just tell right now she's so
easy to talk to and she's got a lot of
love thank you she's just a sweetie yeah
everybody around really seemed to get
along really well incredibly quickly and
Lindy Duncan as well Lindy such a
sweetheart yeah she's great
how's Chris has a dad I think he's gonna
make a great dad someday he's so sweet
he's so kind he does a lot of great
things for children and he does a lot of
great things for charity and he's very
fun and nice and I think that he'd make
a great dad so sweet
contact and this is amazing seriously
you got this whole thing up what was one
of the best parts that would be on set
with him I think any gifts did he give
you any gifts any treats like anything
really I don't know there are any treats
going on candy
I'm doing allowed to have carrion kids
don't eat candy I said no way no I'm not
allowed to have candy no work I'm on or
off set um thanks very much
it was very nice meeting you